if we're talking about Methodists I
should probably put his name right at
the top there is one guy who's
particularly important John was any time
you come across a college I was odds are
it's coming out of the Methodist
Wesleyan holiness traditions he had a
proto to it was very Charles Wesley if
you've gone to churches and heard you
know fairly traditional Church him some
of those are actually been Martin Luther
somewhere by other people summer my is
John Wesley's brother Charles went
through a lot of hymns and were adopted
by a lot of other people and John Wesley
started out in the Anglican Church a
church in vain he any book talks about
some important experiences that he had
there were a lot of changes taking place
think back here you know world history
or early modern history any limb is at
the start is at the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution one of the
Industrial Revolution real to people
besides you know great great goods you
know actually a lot more clothes or some
of the negative impacts of the
Industrial Revolution that you didn't
think up
we don't have a lot of them other than
the pollution part should we displace
them tell their places let me ask you
this what are some of the complaints
people have about this particular piece
of technology and the company that makes
it ethical complaints yeah specifically
what yeah yeah whatever they don't give
them enough piped in music the and a lot
of times it's young kids doing doing
quite a bit of labour in China there's
also the issue of prisoners and that was
using the Industrial Revolution to this
notion about privatizing prisons and
work houses not not something new it's
been around for a couple hundred years
labor conditions were quite bad we've
displaced that other other countries so
we don't we don't see too much of that
something like a food processing but
what we nowadays call sweatshop labor
that was the norm back then there was no
protection for workers if you lost a
hand in a machine that was it for you
hopefully your family would support you
because nobody else is going to and
that's if you didn't die of disease or
infection or something like that or if
you didn't started some some places paid
wages so low that you literally could
not survive on them and Wesley is
concerned with this sort of thing when
you have conditions like that you know
if you want to preach the gospel to
people and say Christianity is all about
helping your fellow man or woman or
child and say Christ is about love and
stuff like that and you're dressed in
really nice clothes and coming in on a
Sunday and the rest of the week these
poor Schmucks are working their their
fingers to the bone in horrible
conditions how Kabul the Zep came out
not too well right it's sort of like you
know if I as a professor were to
complain about you guys not writing 70
page papers for my class and I would
never to publish anything you know and
say these are so lazy I don't think
you'd go for that would you probably not
right get angry at me well you know if
Christianity is going to mean anything
to people and conditions like that it
has to take on different emphasis than
what the Church of England was going to
provide them John Wesley is concerned
with the poor the people who don't fit
into the sort of well-to-do Anglican
spectrum the workers once it gets to the
Americas people on the front here very
attracted to to leslie's doctrine now he
didn't mean for it to go out of the
Church of England he thought the Church
of England fits doing a good job it
should be trying to reach this and it
should also try to reach the religious
factions what we know is all emotion if
Christianity is going to be particularly
meaningful to people it can't just all
be intellectual doctrines and dogmas and
rituals it has to have emotional meaning
in people's lives day after day after
day after day otherwise wisely would say
what's what's the point of them and such
workers the uneducated
what is new is is emphasizing the the
emotions because he thinks that's part
of the human being that's a major part
of you mean think about it this way
you're not happy with all of your
emotions right sometimes you get scared
or sad or angry it's not a lot of fun
being angry something some people like
being angry you have a lot of negative
emotions how many of you have your heart
broken at one time or another wouldn't
that at least half the class right the
rest you broke somebody else's heart
like a pet or you felt disappointed
imagine I could give you a pill so take
all those negative emotions away but you
wouldn't feel any joy or excitement
early positive emotions affection for
other people just be kind of numb and
cold now imagine that you're moving is
really crappy conditions too would you
take the pill if I if I gave it to you
for free if not why not why would that
be a bad bark you know our emotions are
really part of who we hire I think do
you feel like they like I should put it
you think that they're important or do
you feel so important there we already
have that contracts we can select an
emotional when you somebody used the
term passion yeah you used it before
with respect to education if you don't
actually feel any passion about the
stuff that you're studying it's harder
to for it to stick isn't it that's part
of what a good lecture how to do is
actually get you feel as well as to
thank get you interested that's why so
many good right you know they have
lectures putting myself sometimes
on my game what about your major do you
feel passionate about what it is that
you're studying and preparing to do for
maybe not necessarily the rest your life
but for at least the next 20 years I
hope you do because if not it's going to
suck and I don't want that for any of
you especially yeah when you're spending
so much of your ties and effort and
money here to study passion and an
emotion those are very important tho
those are integral part of human beings
and Wednesday was on to them he thought
that the Church of England had become
boring it had become heating as were
born it had become sort of passionless
stultifying he actually had some
theological views tied in with the scrum
and this leads us to this very important
doctrine that he calls sanctification or
another word for this is holiness
sokka's just means that's where did we
get st. from it just means holy so
sanctification becoming only these are
really the same thing yeah brick talks
about you know the early Protestants
were really focused on justification
who's saved who's not saved so Luther
right Luther was was really worried
about is he justified is he saved and he
felt like look I'm a mom kind of doing
all these prayers it's not actually
doing anything for me I still don't feel
like my sins are forgiven what am I
supposed to do and then John Calvin you
know some people are saved some people
are damned some are justified so we're
not justified weslee said well that's
really just the first that's the
beginning of things this would actually
be about sort of progressive I'm call a
progressive development a relationship
with who with God so you know a person
can be closer to God or further away
from God he and as opposed to you like
like you know no worries about
justification imagine a few if you
believe in predestination lawyer your
say to your damn you know you can work
real hard and try to you know do what
the church tells you to do and then
you're probably saved but you're not
actually earning their salvation there's
nothing you can actually do to make it
any better with this this is more
Armenia you actually have some role in
uncle's you already got and how do you
know whether you're closer to God you
can feel it your religious affections
are raised and sometimes that could be
you know painful as a matter of fact if
you look at medieval Saints and the way
that they talk about God some of these
medieval Saints were really great you
know men and women but they would talk
about their consciousness of their own
sins and you know how low the song they
were and sometimes when people get
closer to something transcendent they
become conscious of their own
limitations much more you know just like
I this is a totally different thing but
I I realized that I was not as good at
the guys I thought once I had kids and I
had to take care of kicks you start
realizing your own limitations right
well that's all within the realm of
religious affections and sanctification
and emotion kind of go and hand for
Leslie he talks about this as a second
blessing marked by the attainment of a
state of holiness of transformation of
consciousness characterized by state
freedom from voluntary sin meaning once
you're being sanctified you can still
fall you can screw up you know we get
mad
your neighbor person I'll gossip about
them that would be a bad thing but the
idea is that the further you proceed
into this the easier it gets from
because you know God's helping you out
God's working with him and this this fit
in with a lot of the other things that
we're going on like the revival and
music that is brother Charles Mosley is
carrying on he and another thing that
what brings up that that's important to
keep in mind we're going to talk a lot
more about Methodists later on John and
Wesleyan Charles Wesley were really good
organizers so they're starting a
movement originally it's a movement
within the Anglican Church now
eventually it's going to break away why
do you think they would end up breaking
away Wesley was not you know a big fan
of that actually you wanted to stay in
Anglican just like Luther wanted to stay
a Catholic was it do you think he was
light Luther where he said look I just
cannot put up with us this stuff that
you're doing and I got to take a stand
here I wish it didn't have to be like
this but I'm gonna have to break with
all of you wasn't quite like that so if
it's not the individual actually saying
or the movement saying we're going to
have to part nations how else could
happen that's what's the other
alternative yeah if they're like
ostracized by yeah so tensions arise
within an Anglican Church over this yes
your book talks about some important
some important developments that kind of
set the stage but the tension that's
existing between sort of an established
way of doing things a new way of doing
things that seems to have the vitality
on its side
movement on its side that's underlying
the split your book talks about Wesley
acquainting these these people took to
offices and so Wesley was seen by the
Anglican Church yeah sort of interfering
with church structure with taking on
roles of his own he appoints this guy
thomas thomas cook on a superintendent
now another word for superintendent is
bishop with an anglican church it's very
traditional they have bishops and the
bishops are consecrated by who other
bishops including the Archbishop of
Canterbury so for John Wesley to be
setting this guy up who eventually is
going to tank on but not just him that
but also ashbury these traditional
titles of bishop that's going to cause
some problems and Wesley's not actually
for this but the movement comes to take
out a kind of inertia or impetus of its
own as well and Hammonds right a lot of
times the founder is not completely in
charge of what's going on and where your
book ends up you know through leading
off because is a to be continued kind of
chapters is saying these combinations of
tradition Anglican tradition and
innovative adaptation you know going to
new theology going to new people
discipline an emotion structure and
flexibility democracy and strong
leadership that characterized early
methodism were powerful sources of
Appeal this becomes a major force in the
American colonies and we'll talk about
why as we get into later chapters so